Oh Danny we're really gonna do this
again police has dropped the trailer for
Iron Fist season two so let's start with
a little bit of context for me since I
had gained many subscribers since the
first season which I maja bad it was the
first season of iron fist I did finish
it but I only finished it out of spite
because I I hated it so much I knew I
was gonna have to yell about it and I
knew if I didn't finish it the people
who told me well you didn't even finish
it how do you complain about so I'm like
I have to watch the end of this so that
I am fully justified in yelling about it
so I aided the first season like
everything was bad the fight
choreography was bad the way the fights
were shot was even worse Danny himself
as a character was in sufferable the
hand I've done all recent rant talking
about the hand they are the worst they
are awful just know like there was a
handful of moments tiny aspects little
things just know a whole lot of No so I
don't have a lot of confidence going
into this trailer in fact I saw it
dropped in my media that was crap but
there are a few things I'm trying to
keep in mind the first is that the
showrunner has changed it's no longer
Scott buck because Scott buck is a
cancer of television who needs to not to
be allowed to taint any more properties
ever if you don't know who Scott buck is
not only did he show run iron fist he
was showrunner on Inhumans and more
egregiously to me
he was the showrunner during the last
season of Dexter including during the
single worst series finale in the
history of frigging television but he's
gone he's not on this anymore I don't
know much about the the new person who
is now show running but it doesn't mean
there is the potential for it to pick up
but there were a lot of things that were
wrong beyond just the writing but let's
look at let's actually start getting to
what's in this trailer the action scenes
that we see and the fight scenes that we
see look better in some respects than
they had previously because there were
basically three major problems with the
fight scenes in the first season of iron
fist and they appear to have definitely
fixed two of them and possibly fixed the
third I can't make a call on that those
three problems were the fight
choreography was boring
Danny himself could not sell the
physicality he didn't they the watching
him do it
it didn't can it was not convincing at
all and then finally they were just shot
horribly now these fight scenes look
better choreographed he is definitely
doing much better with the physicality
and we kind of seen that already with
the defenders and then his appearance in
Luke Cage so he has settled into what
this part requires of him physically
much better so that's good I can't say
whether or not the fights are actually
being filmed and edited any better
though because it's a trailer the fight
scenes have been cut up and shortened
and condensed we're only getting a
little snippet so I can't judge that
part of it I'm really hoping that's
better too because if the other two
things are better but it's still shot
like crap I can't see it cuz it's
severely under lit then it won't matter
so fingers crossed they fix that one too
because they fix the other two things so
there's potential there but then Danny
had open his mouth and he said a line
that actually I heard I'm like no no he
didn't say that
I misheard that
and I didn't even want to play the
second time I backed up just that part
of the trailer I was like no he said
that and the thing that he said that
made me go wait a minute
was I didn't ask for the Iron Fist I
suppose on technically that's true
because he didn't ask for it he
willingly participated in a series of
trials culminating in the fight with a
dragon in order to acquire it
so I suppose technically he didn't just
ask for it but he volunteered for this
crap he wasn't forced to take this trial
he chose to do this there's a big part
of what made him so insufferable in the
first season all about I earned the iron
fist now he's treating it like a burden
and look I'm not saying he that he can't
be bogged down by it that there can't be
some sort of you know downside to this
thing that he fought for but you can't
act like this was something that was
thrust upon you what you fought to get
it in the first place I didn't ask for
this yes you did bite me Danny and that
was just that was such an immediate it
brought me right back to everything I
hated about his character in the first
season and I he is just he's the he's
the rich kid with superpowers
complaining about how hard it is to be
him fight me Danny and you know maybe
there's some context for when he says
this maybe if we're really lucky it's a
trailer line it's not in the show at all
or my personal preference
somebody like ideally Colleen upon
hearing him say that goes shut up that's
bull crap if somebody could please call
him out on that the way
not on that moving on from that moment
um
Davos is back which makes me nervous he
wasn't he wasn't the worst thing about
the first season but he wasn't great he
didn't elevate things he didn't help
I'm nervous about having him back
because potentially it means the hand in
some form is coming back I'm still
holding out hope that that isn't the
case though because there's a heck of a
lot of emphasis in this trailer at least
on the personal motivations the personal
grudge between these two which even if
the hand does come back and fingers
crossed they don't but even if they do
that is a good angle to take it at and
actually would be that would that was
one of the big things missing from the
implementation of the hand up to this
point because you know you just had this
nebulous ninja group and you know people
like oh we should stop them cuz they're
bad and there was a lack of personal
stakes if we zero in on this guy who
Danny knows who Danny has a history with
we can get that those personal stakes
and that personal budding heads of a
protagonist and an antagonist that the
first season severely lacked so
potentially he could work and he could
work well and it there obviously I
couldn't I couldn't be sure if he is
getting his own version of the iron fist
or if he's actually taking it from Danny
I'm inclined to think the latter because
I didn't see a scene where Davos lights
up his fist and Danny had his lit so
that to me says that he probably just
flat-out took it but we'll see and
Misty's back which is good I like misty
and I love misty with Colleen I loved
their a little bit in second season of
Luke Cage when they were together was
awesome was great and I want to see her
back and I want to get more from her
especially with Colleen I don't really
care about her and Danny but that's
because
don't really care about Danny I would
love for there to be a daughter so the
Dragons been off with just Colleen and
Misty I would be all for that but but
it's nice to have her back in any case
but that's kind of it those are the
major points and then you know it was
more fighting the music was good and
that that's just kind of it there are
bits and pieces and things that I can
look at and think of okay that has
potential and see how this could
possibly work I'm not getting excited
cuz that first season was but just
atrocious it was there was almost
nothing good about that first season of
this show so I mean I I can't let that I
can't just go oh I'm sure it's fine now
but I'm seeing potential and I I want to
be surprised by this and I'm not seeing
as many red flags as I was expecting to
see still plenty of stuff that concerns
me though so those are my thoughts on
the first trailer I think it's the first
show well it was like the teaser
announcement stuff but like the prop
first proper trailer for Iron Fist
season 2 you've seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff you can do you know what it is
there's links for it down below and
there's buttons that you can press and
all that stuff I have a patreon I'll
mention that but check out the links in
the description if you care and remember
folks you are the council I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]